hallo freunde der sonne ich bin wieder
mal eure chemikerin das vertrauen zu
sich emir in muss man ein ernstes
wörtchen mitreden ich bin gerade in
china und meinen alten studienfreunden
also mit ganz vielen chemikern hier seht
ihr chemiker wichtigkeit beimessen und
direkt am ersten abend kam die
diskussion auf ob ich als chemie
influenza in es verantworten kann andere
zu einem chemie studium zu motivieren
und genießt all das ist klar aber ist
dass die ganze wahrheit
ich werde euch jetzt drei gründe nennen
warum ihren nicht chemie studieren
sollten wenn ihr versprecht dass er
dieses video entweder ganz bis zum ende
oder gar nicht schaut und ich verspreche
euch im gegenzug schonungslos ehrlich zu
sein jetzt wird viel freunde der sonne
holte
setzt euch packen wir nicht lange herum
hier drei gründe gegen ein chemiestudium
nummer eins das chemie studium ist hart
wie hat es das chemiestudium auf einer
skala von 1 bis 10
und sonst doch es ist nicht unbedingt
dafür bekannt und das kann tückisch sein
wenn man sich blauäugig einschreibt und
braucht ein gewisses mathematisch
physikalisches verständnis für bereiche
die thermodynamik oder quad mechanik man
braucht auch ein gutes gedächtnis für
die unmenschlichen mengen an struktur
formeln und reaktions gleichungen die
man einfach auswendig werden muss und
man braucht auch noch ein gewisses
handwerkliches geschick für die ganze
arbeit die man im labor macht ich
persönlich hatte zum beispiel die
probleme in der schule insgesamt ich
fand schule ziehen sie aber die ersten
semester des chemiestudiums haben es mir
schon richtig richtig gegeben aber das
chemiestudium war gut für mich also es
war hart ich bin daran gewachsen nur
diese härte ist vielen gar nicht bewusst
bevor sie ein studium anfangen
das gute ist man muss jetzt kein super
brain sein um ein chemiestudium zu
schaffen
aber man braucht eine sehr hohe
frustration grenze und eine große stress
belastbarkeit manchmal noch mitbringen
auf interessen
ihr verhalten ich durchhalte führen
würden der kokon frustration spenden
also kann für die forschungsarbeiten die
arbeiten wenn du da nicht passt oder
auch nicht also diese scheiß einfach
lieben und machen wollen nummer zwei das
studium ist lag beziehungsweise die
ausbildungs lang 2017 waren es 86
prozent der master studenten die an
ihren master direkt eine promotion also
eine doktorarbeit hinten dranhängen und
nur 11 prozent stiegen nach ihrem
masterabschluss direkt ins berufsleben
ein
weil die meisten einstiegspositionen für
chemiker einen doktor verlangen eine
typische einstiegsposition für einen
chemiker in der industrie ist eine
stelle als laborleiter als laborleiterin
mache ich zwar auch forschung stehe aber
nicht mehr selbst im labor
meistens zumindest nicht das händeln
laborant innen und laboranten die darin
viel besser ausgebildet sind und
meistens auch viel mehr erfahrung haben
was ich mache ist konzeptionieren
organisieren managen ich sitze hier
meetings und so weiter und für diese
aufgabe bereiche wird ein doktortitel
oder eine promotion verlangt so das
durchschnittliche studium dauert bis zum
master 12 7 semester die
durchschnittliche pro portion 8,8
semester man ist also im schnitt fast
elf jahre lang an der uni am ende habe
ich als promovierte chemikerin entsteht
natürlich auch ein höheres
einstiegsgehalt aber dafür fange ich
auch erst viel später an zu arbeiten und
damit kommen wir auch direkt zu punkt
nummer drei nummer drei
die berufsaussichten für chemiker sind
als chemiker machen also eine
doktorarbeit
was machen sie dann ganz grob gibt es
zwei richtungen die man einschlagen kann
entweder man bleibt an der uni oder
hochschule oder man geht in die
wirtschaft in der industrie viele machen
nach der doktorarbeit einen sogenannten
poster und alles was jetzt hier unter
ausland aufgeführt ist das sind auch
posten im ausland ein poster kann der
erste schritt einer akademischen
karriere sein an der uni deren
endstation eine professur ist außer
einer professur gibt es an der uni
leider kaum andere
ihre möglichkeiten und dieser weg ist
super hart denn obwohl ihnen meistens
nur die besten der besten einschlagen
gibt es am ende schlicht und einfach
nicht genügend professoren also nicht
genügend stellen für alle wenn man sich
dann überlegt gut hat jetzt nicht
geklappt mit der professur da gehe ich
jetzt in die industrie dann ist das
meistens schwierig denn man ist dann so
um die 40 jahre alt und muss
konkurrieren mit viel jüngeren leuten
die gerade frisch von der uni kopf oder
frisch aus der doktorarbeit dann gibt es
wirklich nur wenige die irgendeine
andere stelle an der uni oder einer
hochschule bekommen oder auch im
öffentlichen dienst und dann gibt es
natürlich leute die mich die
chemikerinnen des vertrauens werden
beruflich aber ich bin da die absolute
ausnahme als journalistin fande ich
unter freiberufler das sind noch nicht
einmal zwei prozent
also wenn ihr denkt finde ich cool das
team macht möchte ich auch mal machen
und deswegen studiere ich jetzt chemie
nämlich nicht das vorbild ich bin ein
statistisch nicht haltbares vorbild
die meisten rund 46 finden einen job in
der industrie und prinzipiell gibt es
auch nicht wenige stellen für chemiker
in der industrie
zumal deutschland auch eine starke
spielerin pharmaindustrie hat und wenn
ihr euch jetzt nicht für ein
chemiestudium sondern für eine
ausbildung in der chemiebranche
interessiert dann habt ihr momentan sehr
gute chancen denn azubis werden wie in
so vielen anderen bereichen leider
händeringend gesucht nur promovierte
chemiker gibt es runter genügend auf dem
arbeitsmarkt also da gibt es keine
fachkräftemangel
das ändert sich natürlich immer wieder
und wenn ich jetzt anfangen zu studieren
dann hat der derzeitige arbeitsmarkt für
promovierte chemiker natürlich keine
relevanz für euch ich sag das nur weil
diese situation die jetzige
arbeitsmarktsituation immer wieder
aufkommt und wenn ich jetzt als
promovierte chemikerin keine passende
stelle findet dann kann es echt
schwierig werden denn ich bin das
promovierte ja teurer als jemand also
für den arbeitgeber als jemand der einen
master oder bachelor abschluss gemacht
hat weil ich werde ja für meine fach
expertise bezahlt die ich mir während
der doktorarbeit angeschafft habe wenn
jetzt diese fach expertise nicht genau
gefragt das weil diese stelle nicht
exakt passt zu meinem fach expertise
dann würde ich als arbeitgeber lieber
jemanden einstellen mit dem
masterabschluss der günstiger ist als
eine promovierte deren fach expertise
ich sowieso nicht genau nutzen kann also
nicht falsch verstehen die
arbeitsmarktlage für chemiker ist jetzt
nicht die schlechteste um gottes willen
nur sollte man sich klar machen dass in
einem fach wo fast alle einen doktor
machen es durchaus auch nachteile gibt
die man vielleicht nicht unbedingt auf
dem schirm hat so deshalb wenn mich
jemand fragt ob ich ein chemiestudium
empfehlen kann
dann will ich und kann ich das nicht
pauschal beantworten kann man ein chemie
studium empfehlen
ja oder nein aber wenn nicht jemand
fragt ob ich persönlich noch mehr chemie
studieren würde wenn ich die zeit
zurückdrehen könnte
dann ist die antwort einfach nämlich ja
ich meine wenn ihr regelmäßig meine
videos schaut dann ist die ja dass
chemie gael ist es gibt kein atemzug ein
augenblick in dem keine chemischen
reaktionen in die ablaufen
doch ihr müsst jetzt nicht chemie
studieren oder eine ausbildung machen
das wäre ja traurig wenn chemie nur
denen vorbehalten wäre die das beruflich
machen sucht euch videos bücher podcast
es gibt so viele tolle angebote um etwas
über chemie oder über irgendwelche
anderen naturwissenschaften zu lernen
ich mein baby studieren wollte finde ich
echt cool und wir verstehen uns aber ich
sage nur das muss nicht sein jetzt kann
ich eure hilfe gebrauchen bzw
viele die dieses videos schauen können
eure hilfe gebrauchen
lasst eine art meile infobörse aufmachen
wenn ihr erfahrung mit chemie studium
oder ausbildung habt dann teilt diese
erfahrung doch gerne mit den anderen
freunden der sonne in den kommentaren
und damit es den anderen leichter fällt
eure kommentare auch auf den ersten
blick zu sehen beginnt den kommentar
doch gerne mit dem hashtag so ist chemie
die twitterer unter euch können mit
diesem hashtag natürlich ihre erfahrung
auch mit der ganzen welt teilen außerdem
habe ich in der vergangenheit auch schon
ein paar info videos zur chemie studium
und ausbildung gemacht verlinkt ich euch
in der video beschreibung und
hoffentlich hilft euch das alles war der
entscheidung ich grüße euch aus
österreich nächste woche sehen wir uns
dann wieder in gewohnter umgebung bis
dahin